what's up everyone we're still at
Comic-Con 2023 talking about a whole
bunch of stuff that I love I have the
pleasure of sitting next to Robert
Kirkman to discuss Invincible which I
told you I was I was late to the game on
this it was incredible he just came
around in the end it's all fun that's
what matters thank you so much it's like
that's the silver lining of having a
two-year wait is that I had all that
time to catch up and I did it eventually
yes the two-year wit was a good thing we
should do that between every season
that's a good idea shouldn't I'm gonna
get to that in a minute first just a
broad question about season one is there
any particular element of the first
season that surprised you that fans
sparked too that you decided to more
heavily Embrace in the second season oh
my gosh
um
Lord I have so many joke answers there's
so many memes but I don't want to get in
trouble
um but uh I don't know I mean I think
that uh uh you know the the the real
like
you know it's a character drama at its
core and I think that the fact that
people responded to that so much I I was
worried that maybe the audience would
say uh I need more fighting I need to be
more action like this thing slows down
too much and uh I wanted the show to
feel like an hour-long cable drama that
you know had its cool action and was a
superhero story but you know made you
really feel for the characters and and
their journey and uh just to have
everybody respond to that was great so
there's absolutely not even one fight
scene in season two it's spectacular
you really do do every single layer the
drama the fight and the blood and gore
in I mean they all line up especially
well or you feel like the weird bits of
Comedy that as well I appreciate all of
it all right I want to go back to the
the timeline because again it's been a
it's been a two-year wait since season
one so why the weight is it just the
animation process are there any
particular bumps in the road that caused
it maybe something like Ovid it's three
things it's the animation process which
is difficult in and of itself two very
complicated show
um we have a larger cast than you might
see in another in any other show where
uh an hour long cable show or an
hour-long animated show which is very
unusual but we have so many characters
and so many settings even in just one
episode that we're really kind of
pushing the limits of what can be done
in animation so it takes a long time to
make it but it has also taken a long
time to
like learn how to do it and figure it
out because we're doing a lot of things
that you don't necessarily do in
animation and three covet we we debuted
in 2021 and when we got to pick up for
season two and three we had to kind of
figure out we we finished the show like
as covet was starting and for season one
and so we had to like figure out
completely new processes to work with
all the restrictions that came from that
uh you know Animation Studios were shut
down uh you know quite a bit uh during
covid because animators work in like in
a lot of cases large rooms and in giant
groups and so we had to figure out like
a whole new way of working and that
slowed things down quite a bit but I'm
very happy to report that the process of
figuring out all the complexity of the
show and and building the factory that
can generate this show has made it to
where this is the longest period that
there will be between Seasons so things
could should move much more smoothly
from this point on you answered one of
my questions and I like that answer I
like to ramble until I answer as many
questions as possible that you might
have oh I'm here for it so we do know
that we are getting season two but we're
getting it in two parts is is that
decision tied to the production process
or is there something about the season
two storyline that you think will be
benefited from having that break in
between it's a little bit of the
production process just because you know
ramping things up has taken a lot longer
than we thought but also this is
something that we've done with every
season of The Walking Dead and I think
narratively it's kind of cool to have
that pause to digest what you've just
experienced and when you see episode 4
of season two uh you may need a break
it's a big episode it's definitely a
mid-season finale kind of episode and
with everything going on in that time of
year with you know Thanksgiving
Christmas New Year's like all and a lot
of family time uh I think a lot of shows
get lost in the shuffle there and so I
think it's good to take a pause and
narratively it it really May it's going
to make things hit a little bit harder
so so yeah and people know what I'm
talking about when the when the season
launches okay here here's my my greedy
question that you kind of answered so we
can confirm that we won't have as long
of a wait before season three correct
okay correct I like I like hearing that
and I know you always have to look
forward to the future when planning a
series like this so is there any early
development happening on the story
Beyond season three even I mean in my
head I always have plans and I know
exactly like how things would continue
and uh you know there's definitely
discussions but uh uh but you know
nothing I could uh break uh a year but
yeah no questions are good yeah yeah
Amazon or Amazon and and Prime video
very happy with the show you know very
excited about the possibilities of what
we could do were we to have a nice good
long run and so there's a lot of
discussions around that stuff and
hopefully there'll be some good news at
some point I always say it we speak
things into existence
a full season 4 through 14 pickup uh and
if we don't get that I'll be
disappointed I mean I mean it'll be our
fault because the manifestation just did
not work
I'm here for as many seasons as you want
to give us
um I jumped a little far ahead though
because we also know we're getting the
Adam Eve origin story in her own
Standalone episode did you always know
that origin story episode was going to
be for her character and then also do
you have hopes to do any more similarly
styled episodes for other characters in
the future yeah I mean we did that as
the in the comic we did Anatomy
miniseries it was by Benito Sereno and
Nate bellegard and you know it was a
story that I had given them because I
needed somebody to establish Adam he was
backstory because it comes into play in
the in the series proper and so it's
it's a prequel episode that has her
origin but is absolutely essential to
the longevity of the series anyone who's
read the comic knows what I'm talking
about but atomy becomes a bigger and
bigger character as the story of
invincible progresses and so the stuff
that you learn in that episode is very
important so it was always meant to be
an atom Eve episode she's one of our
favorite characters she's one of the
most popular characters in the show and
so uh you know we wanted to really give
her a showcase and as far as like doing
other episodes with different characters
in a similar way uh uh I'd love to we'll
we'll just have to see just for fun is
there any particular you know smaller
supporting character that you have yet
to explore to that extent even in the
comics that I don't know you would just
love to do like a like a fun offshoot
episode I mean there's so many it's hard
to I mean I love battle Beast I'd love
to do something with battle Beast I
think that uh really digging in and and
Monster Girls origin is dealt with in
the comics a little bit but to expand it
out to this level and actually show like
the pathos that comes from like being
trapped in that body and being turned
into a big monster like I don't know
that would be a lot of fun to explore so
but there's a lot of different
characters I'd love to kind of show that
Spotlight on okay well again we're gonna
have 14 Seasons so you have more than
enough time to cover it all right now
I'm tired
all right I want to get into the the
villain a little that you have revealed
for season two angstrom Levy when you're
talking oh no is it leaving it is
leaving oh I purposely wrote Levy I
always I I only did that because even
with like human beings I always will say
whatever I'm not supposed to say with
that particular last name no there's
there's a a great split in fandom where
they're like who what's this how's this
pronounced and it's awesome to have this
show so that people can finally hear the
characters names because on paper
probably should be Levy I've had that
with a lot of book to film adaptations
where I read it and I read everything in
my voice my way and then I hear
something out loud in a final film and I
just can't reprocess the proper way to
say it as confirmed by the filmmakers
Yeah Yeah it's always fun um what is it
about that particular villain that you
think at this point in the show's run
would serve invincibles Arc well that
made you say like this is the villain to
introduce and we have to do it now
I think that I mean there's a lot to it
um a lot of people joke about uh
Invincible hasn't won a fight yet you
know uh it's a superhero show we've had
the first season he's never really
definitively like won an actual conflict
which I think is awesome and so
um we're gonna see him actually start
winning in season two uh uh maybe not
always uh and and maybe in in some ways
a win is a loss and I think that that
kind of comes into play with angstrom
Levy it's it's a villain that he could
if he were able to use his strength
could defeat very easily but this is
going to put him in a place where he has
to take the maturity he's developing now
that his father's gone and and and kind
of use his skills that he's honed as a
superhero uh in a way uh uh he's gonna
have to try to outsmart him instead of
just just beating him up so it puts him
in a position where everything he's
learned doesn't really work for him so
far okay would you describe angstrom
Levy as the big bad of season two or is
it more one of many adversaries that
invisible will face I think he's
probably the big bad of season two but
he's not the only big bad of season two
so there's there's a lot going on in the
season but I think that uh like the uh
Invincible Omni man conflict was kind of
the through line of the of the first
season
um what happens with angstrom Levy uh
kind of carries over the entire season
in a way that some of the other stories
don't okay and in my my research
angstrom Levy has Multiverse
capabilities
first just more broadly like what do you
think it is about whatever phase we're
in in storytelling where everyone is
obsessed with Multiverse yeah I mean
it's it's it's it's funny because uh I
didn't know I don't think I knew about
far from home or spider-verse or uh
maybe spider-verse was out but like when
we decided to do this for season two I
don't know like I didn't know that that
was a Flash movie so uh it's literally
everywhere
um I don't know I don't know what it is
about it I think it's a it's a it's a
great tool to kind of uh use to bring
different incarnations of things in
which I think is uh kind of becoming a
uh uh you know like I'm gonna say easy
button it's like ah let's make this cool
uh bring that guy from that other thing
in here bring that guy from that other
thing in here
um and so uh it's it's super cool and as
a fan I love it uh but uh um I will say
that we're using angstrom Levy's
Multiverse capabilities in a in a much
different way
um you know it's not just about you know
pulling different different things that
you may love into a story through the
Multiverse it's a very character driven
story there's a lot of drama to it
um you know seeing the the sliding doors
aspect of another dimension and and and
and and finding out like how things went
a different way when different decisions
were made uh we're kind of drilling it
down to its its simplest form and and
it's not this this massive uh uh try not
to say the word unwieldy but you know
whatever uh uh thing okay okay I like
the sound of all that
um this is
a tough question maybe but I'm I'm
curious is there anything you wrote for
yourself in season one that you found
yourself having the most challenging
time writing yourself out of like or or
finding the most creative solution to
expand that particular plot point in
season two right I I don't think so I
think that I mean we had the the comics
as a guidepost which is kind of a kind
of a cheat code for making a TV show to
a certain extent because you can it's
great uh we didn't have this with
Walking Dead because the comics weren't
done yet but with Invincible we can
literally read the last issue oh it
might be neat to to plant this thing
here in season two that may come into
play if we're lucky enough to get to
season 14
um you know so it's it's uh you know you
know we're kind of following that road
map to a certain extent
um I think there's a lot of deviations
that we're able to do in season one that
it's fun to pick those up and to run
with those balls because we have to kind
of do different things because we uh
kind of change the Playboy look a little
bit in the first season so there's that
aspect of it but there definitely isn't
that like that brilliant like into that
season of Star Trek with Picard as Borg
and then sit there for six months going
how are we gonna how are we gonna follow
this up I don't know we're gonna follow
this up we haven't been able to write
ourselves into that corner just yet but
maybe maybe it's an exciting creative
challenge I feel like when you write
yourself into a corner you have to
really sit and think about how to write
yourself out of it
um a season one and season two question
here sure which character of the bunch
wound up being more creatively
fulfilling to bring to screen in that
format in season one like than you ever
could have imagined but then I also want
the answer for season two who surprised
you mostly yeah season one I love Cecil
and Donald and Donald especially
R.I.P
um but uh uh he he just turned out great
and Christy Montopolis who does Donald's
voice is spectacular I would marry
Walton Goggins if I wasn't already
married I love that guy so much uh so
his Cecil Stedman is is just spectacular
I can't say who plays him because it's a
reveal later but for season two the
character is shapesmith I think
shapesmith he was a fun character in the
comic and he brought a cool Dynamic and
the way he affected the larger Martian
storyline was very interesting but uh
the actor whom I almost just named uh
does so much with him and brings so much
to the character it is just absolutely
amazing and as I'm saying that I also
have to throw out a shout out to Jeffrey
Donovan for machine hit in season one he
is also another actor that came in and
was like nope I'm going to make this
character 400 times better than you
thought it could be which you know is uh
is is great you know in in the middle of
a sag strike let's talk about how much
these actors bring to these roles and
how absolutely essential they are like
they they really do breathe life into
everything in ways that people who
aren't behind the scenes could never
anticipate when you hear Jeffrey Donovan
playing Machine Head you may think oh
that's that's some good writing
but you you never can like you know and
writers are great too I'm a writer
whatever I don't know where I'm going
here I'm lost well cannot emphasize that
point nearly enough what you do is is
like pretty much a miracle to bring any
show movie anything to screen whatsoever
and every single artist and there are
hundreds if not thousands of them
involved in every single project we
watch deserves to be treated fairly for
their work and celebrated in a way that
makes it uh it makes the experience
creatively fulfilling but also makes
them feel like they're getting what they
deserve I can't emphasize that enough
um one here's like a really obnoxious
logic question for you because I love
lore and things like that I hope I have
an answer for you so Invincible is
essentially impenetrable except for like
the most advanced intense Weaponry ever
in your mind how has he operated on by
human beings how can like things like
needles
penetrate his skin
I think that one of the things that is
that I try to achieve with Invincible
that I think is is is magical is to
never consider those things I think that
the
we had a thing that they would not let
me do on the show where if you read the
comic invincible's house makes
absolutely no sense it's like an MC
Escher design there's a door here that
goes outside but if you look at the room
from the other angle the front door's
there and so it's like so the house is
one room wide that doesn't make any
sense and that works in comics you can
just bend reality around what is the
most entertaining and what is the is is
the coolest and I I that is something
that I think is
kind of what makes superhero stories
special you know you can have someone
that can fly around the world and get
take out but you don't spend time
worrying that it's going to vaporize
when they move that fast
um you know it's it's selectively
ignoring the things that yeah you know
Mark and Nolan are playing baseball
standing back to back throwing a
baseball around the circumference of the
earth how many birds did they kill how
many planes did they crash how many
Avalanches did they cause how many Sonic
Booms that you know like wreaked havoc
across the world in that none because
they're just playing baseball and it's
fun and it's cool but if you start
thinking about the reality of it it it
it it it it it drags things down and so
uh I think that there's a jackhammer
that they have that cuts into Mark's
skin and that's what allows him to do
surgery different type of stuff that
keeps me up at night now I'm gonna lose
many nights worth of sleep thinking
about the poor birds that died for a
game of catch sorry it's okay I'll deal
with it also if you throw a baseball
fast it might ignite the atmosphere
anyway
I ca I could spin out of control
thinking about all that but that's
that's what I love too is I love when
those things aren't weighing heavily on
my mind while I'm thinking while I'm
watching the show but I like to fill in
those blanks after the fact and like and
come up with my own reasons for for why
like
well he's like in my mind he is weakened
and that reduces all of his powers in
which case he would need to be stitched
up by human doctors and they can't we're
doing it I'm fine with that I'll end
with one question just to tease what
everyone can look forward to in season
two do you have a particular favorite
episode and what can you tease about why
that is your favorite episode of the new
season
jeez
[Music]
207 maybe okay okay there's a scene in
207 a season two episode seven sorry
that's TV and I get it I apologize for
anyone out there episode seven of season
two has like
a scene that I've been dying to adapt
from the comics into the show and uh uh
it's just it I can't wait for people to
see the way that we changed it because
it couldn't couldn't be done in the same
way I'm speaking in code now uh because
of the way it is in the comics and so uh
we had to change it completely and so we
kind of had to like rebirth a fan
favorite iconic scene in a way that
works in animation so it's the same but
it's 100 100 fundamentally different so
I want to see if it has the same effect
and is is is as beloved so look out for
that scene so rock solid uh tease right
there I'm eager I'm eager to see it I'm
very I'm very grateful that I was
encouraged to finally discover the show
and now I'm okay with the break between
the two parts of season two because
that's when I can go and discover all
the source material as well absolutely
also so I could see the effects of
changing that scene for 207 I can't wait
Robert huge congratulations done
everything you accomplish and also
season two of this show I cannot wait
thank you so much